j'en avais pas au bonjour Alors Emmanuel
Macron veut la semaine prochaine réunir
l'ensemble des forces politiques
l'ensemble de l'opposition l'ensemble de
la majorité est-ce que c'est la seule
manière de sortir
de l'enlisement politique que l'on
constate dans cette deuxième année du
quinquennat il faut se rappeler que face
à des situations politiques inédites
face à des défis inédits le président de
la République a par le passé pris des
initiatives inédites c'est le grand
débat national après les gilets jaunes
c'est la convention citoyenne pour le
climat face aux grands défis climatiques
des moyens de revitaliser de débloquer
la démocratie lorsqu'elle semblait
paralysée cette initiative ça sera
l'occasion de tracer des des lignes de
consensus là où les forces politiques
peuvent se retrouver il y en a il y a
des marges la preuve par exemple c'est
que le projet de loi numérique que j'ai
porté au Sénat juste avant l'été a été
adopté à l'unanimité du Sénat vous
espérez que que l'opposition joue le jeu
l'été dernier le président de la
République souhaitait exclure de ce
dialogue le rassemblement national et la
France insoumise il réintègre ces deux
parties en tout cas il les invite à
l'élyser ou peut-être hors de l'Élysée
la la semaine prochaine vous pensez que
l'opposition va jouer le jeu il intègre
toutes les forces politiques
représentées au parlement à ce jour un
certain nombre d'entre elles ont répondu
présent notamment dans l'opposition et
je le disais nous ne sommes pas d'accord
sur tout mais il y a un certain nombre
de sujets sur lesquels les Français
attendent que nous puissions agir que
nous puissions avancer et nous avons vu
l'année dernière alors que la majorité
est relative alors que la situation est
compliquée un certain nombre de textes
être adoptés y compris à l'unanimité
alors le ministre de l'Intérieur Gérard
lormain fait aussi ça rentrait politique
ce sera dimanche à Tourcoing pour un
déjeuner saucisse frites vous êtes
invité vous distrait vous savez j'ai
beaucoup d'estime pour Gérald Darmanin
pour son action et puis pour l'attention
qu'il accorde au classe populaire qu'il
a voulu mettre à l'honneur à l'occasion
de sa rentrée je n'ai pas besoin d'aller
à Tourcoing pour lui témoigner de cette
estime et vous savez d'ailleurs que
Gérald Darmanin sera présent aux
journées de rentrer du groupe modem dans
quelques semaines et nous aurons pas de
Bizzbee entre le modem et un petit mot
sur les classes populaires et puisque
Gérard Darmanin non seulement il met
effectivement au centre de sa rentrée
politique les classes populaires mais il
dit que le gouvernement ne s'est pas
parlé justement aux Français les plus
modestes et il vous taxe vous les
ministres de techno je crois que quand
on s'engage en politique il faut en
permanence cultiver sa capacité
d'indignation face à l'ordre établi les
classes populaires ce sont celles qui
sont souvent oubliées il faut quand on
est engagé en politique constamment se
mettre à leur service mais je crois que
c'est ce que nous avons fait depuis 6
ans avec le président de la République
et aujourd'hui avec la première ministre
alors retour au numérique avec d'abord
une question sur un site dont on parle
beaucoup un site pour les jeunes qui
s'appellent rencontre ADO.NET on en
parle beaucoup en ce moment est-ce que
vous mettez en garde
par an qui ont justement des ados sur le
fait que et bien ce site pour être
abriter des prédateurs sexuels oui bien
sûr mais avant ça je veux dire que je
partage
l'indignation là aussi d'un certain
nombre de parents qui m'ont écrit
directement pour me signaler des des
situations qu'ils avaient constaté sur
ce site rencontre ado de 13 à 25 ans sur
lesquels effectivement des mineurs de 15
ans des moins de 15 ans peuvent être en
relation avec des adultes donc face à à
ces signalements qui se sont multipliés
ces dernières semaines j'ai saisi la
procureur de la République sur des
situations particulières qui traduisent
des propositions par des adultes à des
mineurs des propositions sexuelles ce
qui est passible de deux ans de prison
il faut le rappeler je veux dire à ceux
qui se livrent à ce type de comportement
criminel qu'ils peuvent être retrouvés
qui peuvent être condamnés et j'ai pris
contact avec le site en question avec
lequel je vais échanger aujourd'hui pour
améliorer sa coopération avec les
autorités de police et de justice mais
je veux dire plus généralement que ce
type de situation n'est pas acceptable
et que si nous voulons instaurer la
confiance dans l'espace numérique alors
il faut que nos enfants soient protégés
lorsqu'ils sont sur internet mais est-ce
qu'ils sont protégés par exemple on
constate depuis maintenant des années la
surexposition des des jeunes des ados à
tout ce qui est image pornographiques
est-ce que le projet de loi que vous
défendez va permettre enfin on a envie
de dire de temps de résoudre cette
question nos enfants sont insuffisamment
projetés aujourd'hui sur Internet et
nous sommes vous le vous l'avez dit en
train de nous doter d'un certain nombre
d'outils le projet de loi qui a été
adopté au Sénat qui va être examiné dans
quelques semaines à l'Assemblée
nationale va permettre d'ordonner le
blocage des sites pornographiques qui ne
vérifieront pas l'âge de leurs
utilisateurs aujourd'hui il y a dans
notre pays
d'enfants qui chaque mois sont exposés à
des contenus pornographiques avec des
conséquences délétères pour leur santé
pour leur développement affectif pour
leur bien-être il faut y mettre fin avec
ce projet de loi nous nous y
parviendrons mais ça n'est qu'une étape
il va falloir aller beaucoup plus loin
pour assurer la sécurité de nos enfants
sur Internet il y a demain un moment
important qui est l'entrée en
application d'une nouvelle
réglementation européenne qui va mettre
au pas les grandes plateformes de
réseaux sociaux en leur imposant des
obligations nouvelles et parmi ces
obligations il y a une meilleure
protection de nos enfants contre la
publicité ciblée contre le harcèlement
etc alors on en parle un peu
effectivement dans les domaines dans le
dans le domaine spécialisés de ce
nouveau règlement numérique européen
est-ce qu'il va permettre aussi
de mettre en cause la responsabilité des
réseaux sociaux Emmanuel Macron on s'en
souvient avait pointé leur
responsabilité lors des émeutes urbaines
est-ce que demain il sera plus possible
d'appeler au pill aux incendies sur les
réseaux sociaux la réponse est oui et
c'est très important parce que il faut
que les Français et vos auditeurs
étaient spectateurs le sachent jusqu'à
présent les plateformes de réseaux
sociaux n'étaient tenues responsable de
rien ce sont les auteurs ou les éditeurs
de contenu problématiques qui étaient
mis en cause désormais ce ne sera plus
le cas et les réseaux sociaux auront une
responsabilité vis-à-vis des contenus
qui transit sur leur plateforme et c'est
très important dans le contexte des
émeuts puisque quelques jours après le
début des événements nous avons avec
Gérald Darmanin convoquait les grandes
plateformes pour les
pour le rappeler leurs obligations
légales de retrait des contenus
illicides de réponses aux réquisitions
de la justice et nous leur avons demandé
d'aller un peu plus loin pour mettre en
oeuvre des mesures qui vont être
obligatoires au terme de ces nouvelles
règles européennes pour assurer la
sécurité publique ou éviter en tout cas
que leur service ne la mettent ne la
mettent en cause nous avons à la demande
de la première ministre créer un groupe
transpartisan qui s'est réuni deux fois
qui rassemble 14 groupes politiques du
Sénat et de l'Assemblée comme quoi quand
le l'intérêt supérieur du pays est en
jeu les voies du consensus peuvent être
trouvées et le président de la
République rassemblera l'ensemble des
ministres concernés par le sujet des
émeutes dans quelques jours pour tirer
les leçons un mois après les événements
de ce que nous devons faire pour éviter
que cela ne se reproduise merci beaucoup
Joëlle d'avoir été l'invité de France
Info télé ce matin merci